[MUSIC PLAYING]
I wanted to show you one of my
favourite props from last
year's Christmas Lectures, which
is a Mobius strip steel
track, covered in maybe 2,000 or
3,000 of these super strong
neodymium magnets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what I want to show you is
how this track is going to
interact with one of these.
This is a high temperature
superconductor, made of
yttrium barium copper oxide.
It's a sort of ceramic
material.
And a superconductor is
something that, when you cool
it down, in this case with
liquid nitrogen, it loses all
its electrical resistance.
So this leads to some
interesting behaviours, which
I'm going to show you.
And to do that I'm going to need
to hang this thing from
the ceiling, which
I'll do now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh!
So we have one suspended,
super strong, neodymium
magnetic Mobius strip track.
What we need now is some
liquid nitrogen.
So we're down in one of
the labs at the RI.
And this is where the liquid
nitrogen is stored.
Right.
Got what we need.
The superconductor is now
cooling down, which will take
a minute or so.
It needs to be cooled down in
situ, because, one, what I'm
trying to get to is to have a
superconductor kind of locked
into this position.
So I need to cool it down
in situ above the track.
I'm cooling it down past it's
critical temperature, the
temperature at which it will
become a superconductor, and
its electrical resistance will
completely disappear, which is
about minus 180 degrees.
And the burger tray is there
to maintain the spacing
between the superconductor
and the track.
I mentioned that we're
trying to lock it
into a specific position.
So that is the position that
we want it to take up.
I'm just going to
slide this off.
This is the best way I've
found of doing this.
If you ever hold it so quickly
enough you can see that it's
actually levitating
on the track.
Actually, you might be able to
see a gap underneath it there,
sliding back and forth,
levitating.
Oh!
OK.
So unfortunately, it warms
up quite quickly.
Obviously, the effect only works
as long as it is at its
superconducting temperature.
So what's actually going on
there, a good way to start to
understand that is to think
about how magnets interact
with ordinary conductors,
like this copper tube.
So if I just drop this nut
through, it falls all the way
through very quickly,
as you'd expect.
If I drop a strong magnet
through instead, it takes
quite a long time.
So the reason that's happening
is as the magnet moves through
the copper, it induces electric
currents in the copper.
Those electric currents,
themselves, have their own
magnetic field.
And that magnetic field will
always arrange itself so as to
resist the motion that's
creating it.
This is the fundamental
principle of electromagnetism,
the moving magnets.
And the conductors are moving
conductors near magnets,
creating electric currents.
Now, because this is not a
superconductor, because it has
electrical resistance, the
currents that are created as
the magnet falls through will
always tend to die away.
So if the magnet were, for
instance, to be stopped by the
electric currents, those
currents would immediately die
away, and the magnet would
start falling again.
So what actually happens
is it just falls
slowly through the tube.
If, however, this were a
superconductor those currents
would not die away.
As soon as you induce them by
introducing the magnets into
the tube, those currents would
remain and would keep going
and would keep going even after
the magnet has stopped.
So if this were a
superconductor, the magnets
would basically be locked
in the pipe.
They would be effectively
levitating in the pipe
indefinitely.
So that's part of
the explanation.
We are sort of halfway there.
And we'll get onto
the track now.
And to do that, we saw, when
I was demonstrating the
superconductor on the track
down here, that the effect
only lasted a few seconds.
It warmed up too quickly.
It warmed above its critical
temperature and stopped
levitating.
The solution we've decided on
for the Christmas Lectures
dossier was to make
it a little train
stroke, boat thing.
So we've got a piece of the
superconductor embedded in
polystyrene with its own little
reservoir for liquid nitrogen.
So let's cool this down.
Again, it's not a burger
tray this time.
It's a slightly different
dish.
Gently pick it up.
And I think--
So now I can send her out.
Come all the way back.
Come back on top.
This is why we made it like a
Mobius strip, so that it can
go and come back on the opposite
side it went around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So if I stop it there.
So it's kind of locked
into position.
So it's not just repelling
the magnets and hovering.
I can sort of pick it up and
then stick it underneath as
well, and it will hang there.
So as I mentioned with the
copper, when you induce
electric currents in conductors
with a moving
magnetic field or changing
magnetic flux, the electric
currents that you create will
always have their own magnetic
field that resists
that change, that
resists that motion.
So when it's hovering on top of
here, gravity is trying to
pull it towards the track.
That small motion toward sets
up the electric currents in
the superconductor, which have
a magnetic field that resist
that motion.
But likewise, when it comes
around and is now on the other
side, now gravity's trying
to pull it away.
So the act of trying to fall
away from the track sets up a
different sets of currents
with a different magnetic
field, which this time are
attracted to the track.
So whichever way you try and
move it, whether you're trying
to move it off to the side, up
and down, towards the track,
away from the track, the
superconductor will resist
that motion, effectively locking
itself into position
relative to the track.
So the only direction it can
move is the direction which
the magnetic field doesn't
change, i.e.
along the track.
So basically, the superconductor
can be any kind
of magnet it wants to be, or any
kind of magnet it needs to
be at that moment to keep itself
in the right position
relative to the track.
So this material was a real
breakthrough and possibly the
first step on the way to what
might be the holy grail of
superconductor research, which
would be a superconductor that
would operate at room
temperature or close to room
temperature.
At which point, we might be able
to use them to replace
all of the conventional
conductors, like copper and
things, that we use in all our
electrical applications today.
And all those materials, when
they conduct electricity they
do it inefficiently to some
extent and waste energy.
If we could superconduct in
those applications, then that
would really change the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]